jeux de société herbiers poupée ou
encore jeux de marelle
la collection est large au musée du
jouet qui présente son exposition jardin
d'enfance se trouve que maintenant après
de confinement n'est pas encore plus on
a encore plus envie de sortir envie de
profiter de la nature donc voilà voir
les les jouets du jardin rencontrer tous
ces jeux auxquels on joue les enfants
d'autrefois et ceux d'aujourd'hui en
lien avec les extérieurs ça un vrai
attrait pour le public
en plus de l'exposition des jouets en
intérieur les jardins du musée sont
aussi accessibles et vont accueillir au
mois de juillet des ateliers
alors le don il ya toutes les joies qui
sont eux évidemment à l'intérieur des
vitrines qu'on ne peut pas toucher donc
c'est toujours un peu frustrant pour les
enfants de voir des choses et pas
pouvoir jouer avec
donc on organise autour de l'exposition
toute une programmation d'animations et
d'ateliers durant lesquelles les enfants
vont découvrir certains de ses jeux et
pouvoir les pratiques et les enfants de
4 à 12 ans pourront participer à ces
ateliers
la visite est possible dès le plus jeune
âge les jeux par le plus grand nombre
on considère qu'à partir de quatre ont
en fait l'exposition et certains
ateliers sont accessibles pour les
enfants et puis on va dire que ça va
pour les ateliers c'est jusqu'à 12 ans
après l'exposition elles évidemment elle
intéresse aussi tous les adultes jusqu'à
tous les âges est ouverte seulement un
mois que du confinement l'exposition est
exceptionnellement prolongé jusqu'à la
fin de l'année pour permettre aux
visiteurs de mieux en profiter